[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
assuré
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
juste serré bien les jambes est mêlé
c'est déjà pas mal
on va voir votre deuxième nez et un et
vaut mieux que deux tu l'auras
merci d'être avec nous en direct qu'est
ce qu'un bon aujourd'hui dans soit
quillan et qui coule
[Applaudissements]
il va devoir lalbenque élégance même
vannes fait par jean-michel même serait
son armateur méchant mais c'est ça qui
fut maire jean michel bergeron leur ai
dit tu sors jean-luc ça passe attention
c'est le conseil de classe de gilles
verdez sont avides de conseils de classe
depuis le début capucines à naves et
valérie bénaïm vous notez également
gilles verdez chez vous et je vous
donnerai ma note aussi mme annoot est
aussi à valérie bénaïm et à capucine est
là parce que je n'ai pas fait la dans la
foi et je dire exactement ce que je
pense de gilles verdez on a faim de
votre début de saison gilles verdez
regardez c'est du gilbert dette
[Musique]
anti sociale pouvait très coincé crispé
mal à l'aise dans les interviews à ses
déplacements n'importe quoi elle
fourre-tout antisocial jour viendra je
suis heureux d'être avec vous ce soir
c'est une des barreaux qui fixe et un
kafka 17 à gap
c'est une autre nature
j'ai l'humilité de reconnaître que dit
beaucoup de conneries vulgaire neige se
sont posés le casque est très très très
très très attendu on va d'abord avoir
l'appréciation et la note ensuite
l'appréciation d'abord de thierry moreau
fait d'abord appréciation et après la
note pour terminer thierry mots c'est un
très bon camarade il est super sympa le
seul problème c'est le niveau sonore
sais pas combien d'années de printemps
percée dans l'équipe des arguments d'une
mauvaise foi absolue
bien que tu sais plus tu cries on arrive
même à crier en posant des questions
quand on parle de chiffres
certes tu cries tout le temps voilà donc
bilan mitigé donc voilà je mets 4 4 4 4
projets verts pour la camaraderie merci
je donnerai mon addiction sévère mais
chez hertz en mer donnerai mon avis sur
enora malagré gilles est un poème gilles
est un astre et gilles est essentielle à
l'émission quand parfois l'ambiance est
un peu molle et moi et l'autre sont
déployés sur la tête de ma mère là on
sait tous qu on avait l'impression
d'être vous savez en arts plastiques
avec la marque est un peu ça y est
toujours une pensée en arts plastiques
madame boudarène les eaux fou merci
d'être là parce que la vie la vie
s'éteint c'est aux poèmes entre la mafia
et 2009
sortez sortez une fois et de papier
canson et en arts plastiques à long
terme encore alors alors allez-y côte il
est essentiel à l'émission quand parfois
l'ambiance est peut-être un peu molle
une intervention gilles et partout on
repart et ginette un bosseur et ça ce
n'est même pas moi qui le dit c'est la
rédactrice en chef emily lopez de
l'émission gilles est vraiment un
acharné du travail c'est celui qui
propose le plus de choses
un de ceux et moi quand j n'est pas là
et bien ces jeux j'ai l'âme en peine et
puis gilles est un chevalier avec les
femmes notamment avec moi alors je
t'aime et je t'aime et 8 ou gilles
verdez donc codéine aura une très bonne
note vous êtes touchés je suis ému et
parce que les larmes aux yeux c'est beau
ce qu'elle a dit jamais vous dirait
quelque chose comme ça de moi pas tu vas
tu es sécher avec nous
[Applaudissements]
jean luc lemoine notre appréciation pour
gilbert be alors j ai quelqu'un
d'exalter et je suis d'accord avec enora
indispensable à l'émission c'est
quelqu'un qui est dans l'air du temps
je rappelle que les dirigeants du monde
en ce moment c'est kim jong hoon
poutine donc il faut quelqu'un comme
gilles verdez cet état qui a du flair je
rappelle que l'année dernière disait que
iris mittenaere ne méritait pas d'être
miss france de pied les miss univers
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai qu'il ya vraiment du flair et
c'est un mec qui comme le disait tout à
l'heure
thierry c'est un vrai bon camarade et il
est vraiment essentiel donc julien bon 7
7% il a donc des bonnes notes de garder
vos notes yoplait vichy ricimer donc on
est toutes les notes de tout le monde
merci les chéris attention je voudrais
ma taille à payer à laurent baffie
laurent tu mettras une note agile sans
rigoler serre et équipements chérie tu
mettras la note
3-0 à jean par méchanceté bien tu restes
là mon laurent merci mon lolo
alors jean michel maire non emballés les
médailles ballet votre note pour gildas
alors d'abord votre appréciation
gilles tu as fait un excellent premier
trimestre tu as fait beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'efforts par rapport à l'année
dernière
tu arrives à prendre sur toi et a
commencé à maîtriser un petit peu ce que
disait micra c'est à dire tu es
emportements ta voix un peu excessive et
ses petits problèmes encore tu voit des
complots partout
ah oui alors il faut arrêter avec les
complots gilles n'y a pas de forcément
des complots tout le temps tout le temps
tout le temps en revanche effectivement
tu travaille énormément et eu un vrai
gentil et c'est pour cela que je te mets
un excellent 5 et demi par hal gill pour
l'instant c'est merveilleux oui mais
j'ai gardé le ski va ça va se gâter
wayne sabaj gatti a tout de suite avec
benzema castle mon petit gilles que dire
sur gilles aucune critique constructive
des partis pris à une quête à la place
du cerveau quand il dit nabila s'emporte
à tort et à travers eux ne sait pas se
contrôler et nous mêmes ces enquêtes
sont partielles et partiales
bref pour moi c'est une question
[Applaudissements]
et me dit regarde mais que des notes
pour la guinée bref rien d'autre qui
juste préciser de qui vous parlez et
gilles verdez donc pour moi c'est une
vraie catastrophe nucléaire en revanche
là où je suis très embêté c'est que j'ai
découvert gilles verdez et là je suis
heureuse dans la vie il a un coeur comme
ça donc
et j'avais dû noter à l'extérieur
plateau aurait misé sans aucun doute un
oeuf
mais là malheureusement je mets 1 2
dr gilles de la note de benjamin
castaldi
moi c'est ça notre caisse où les gens
michel mr oui gilles on s'affronte
souvent sur le plateau parce que c'est
vrai que des arguments sont complètement
délirant d'une mauvaise foi mais tout un
incroyable je vous dis vous il a souvent
raison plus souvent raison que mathieu
bord pour vos pronostics mathieu samedi
soir on va voir tout à l'heure
jean-michel il se prend pour un grand
justicier monf on n'a pas besoin de
procureur ni de justice et en france on
se débrouille très bien son toit d
enquête bâclée mais à peine commencée
voilà ça m'étonne la journaliste de
talent teneur en revanche je te connais
je te reconnais une grande qualité
c'était toujours à l'heure à l'émission
donc de mes deux raquettes n'est pas
c'est pas notre plaisir à personne
ils savent que de regarder c'est
vachement cher zabel mauvaise passe
alors mangent ils avec qui j'ai une
relation de laurent a marqué juste sur
la redresse compenser d'isabelle mais
vous nous montrez après on nous montre
après avec une fois qu'elle affine et
flacons et merci alors isabelle à daisy
alors moi jle je le trouve passionnant
passionné et il passionne absolument
tout sur tout ce qui a pas lieu de
l'être et donc de ce point de vue là il
est assez fascinant mais réussir est
juste il y avait des mouches ils
s'étaient tous dans le bonheur d'y être
imprévisible dans ses opinions servir
aux médias il va taper sur tel endroit
et maintenant ce jour-là il tape sur
autre chose donc il me fait penser à un
arrosage de jardins
laurent pendant qu'elle parle
est ce que cela veut dire ce que vous
pensez de balle et les médaillons merci
merci merci merci laurent blanc ont
porté le voile est levé 10 alors que le
site fonctionne exactement t'apprêtes à
rosas 2 après on faire mouvement
alternatif où ses fans où il va aller
mal et envoie lundi je les aime
profondément dans la vie je n'oublie pas
qu'au ski on a bien compagne sonné
ensemble
bref c'est mon poto ils font pas de
vieux murs et donc on juge tendrement un
amidon venu mais merde pardon pour lui
et metella s'est fait pas mal c'est
pareil
aurélie de laurent vous avez jamais ce
que vous pensez de valérie bénaïm pour
nous m pour lui m on attend l'infiniment
shakoor pardon ce que je n'avais pas mes
affaires ce que ma mère était malade les
gens vraiment attention matthieu
delormeau et vous nous mettrait alors
mettez vous aussi ce que vous pensez de
matthieu delormeau derrière vous êtes
vous êtes un ami à lui matthieu
delormeau le mathieu dangereux dit que
vous êtes un ami à lui on a tout on a
beaucoup parlé de ça où on est potes
ouais ouais bah voila mon meilleur ami
on se connaît c'est vrai c'est votre
amie tombe bien vous l'avez déjà paix je
savais pas qui c'était il ya 20 minutes
et rené pas en otage je ne connais pas
cette place alors mathieu la note de gil
evans un grossiste à l'ordre aleris au
passé six ans valérie je crois que c'est
pour matthew rush vers ça me touchait
merci alors elle est maintenant pour
matthieu bonduelle c'est sûr si tu t'es
payé aux conneries que tu dis tu serais
milliardaire je crois pas que soit le
cas mon chou ce qui est sûr c'est que
pour la 6e ou deux minutes tu mets tout
au même niveau et parfois ça m'agace
parce que tu oublies même quelques mois
en direct les gens qui regardent la
télévision et que parfois ça port du
sens que tu dis par exemple tu vas me
manquer de gueule avant ajoutant avoir
maintenant qu'est-ce que je peux lancer
le générique annoncez votre premier
league faut que je lance scutella
dimanche vous attendez vous allez voir
vous n'allez pas être déçus
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être avec nous d'un magnat du
morgen alors on y voit tel projet parce
que magali magail hydrique alors et vous
travaillez ou magali testait les poches
et les stars étaient les poches et ouais
elle est partout et leurs magazines très
jolie en plus
et merci d'être là c'est notre expert
média du jour et laurent nouvel atout
d'adieu qu'est ce que vous avez sur
matthieu delormeau homophobes
[Applaudissements]
rien qu'à l'heure de me demander ni l
arène comme ça dans le privé aussi
bayonnais gens ne prennent pas souvent
les hommes en 10 janvier
non mais laurent était souple est un
souci si on se calme pas je l'attends
sera donc si on ne peut pas regarder ce
qu'on leur demande et coûte au total on
se calme au loto c'est que je t'aime
plus qu'un morandini les gens les côtes
alors oui voilà oui monsieur
non mais ça va vraiment le monde se
trompe ce nombre
allez au bain mathieu il est sympa votre
pote banon mais on se bat tout le togo
ont dîné tous vont se battre comme ça il
sait qu'on va les aider en cuisine
allez allez on y va alors je disais
comprenait tout début du championnat je
disais tu mets tout au même niveau et
comme tu veux tout le temps faire le
show être un peu différent des autres
pour la caméra sur toi parce que tu
adores ça tu te rends pas compte qu en
direct et qu'on n'est pas sur scène et
que ce que tu dis parfois ça peut avoir
du sens pour les gens qui regardent
exemple tu vas mettre au même niveau un
énorme coup de gueule sur koh lanta que
tu va pousser qui est aberrant et à côté
de ça pour être différent des autres
eh ben tu veux dire que par exemple
voter plusieurs fois aux primaires
contiennent très chic on peut voter
plusieurs fois ça c'est pas grave comme
tu es sûr que tu vas un petit peu sortir
du lot et qu'on va te regarder et
pourtant si c'est important les gens qui
regardent la télévision voter plusieurs
fois aux primaires c'est une triche
c'est grave
tu mets tout au même niveau tu veux tout
le temps faire le show on sait même plus
ce qui est vrai du faux
les anecdotes que tu racontes tout avis
personnel voilà c'est très drôle mais du
coup on sait jamais si c'est vrai c'est
faux c'est plus une télé réalité quand
on le voit on sait jamais qui est le
vrai gilles d'ailleurs dans la vraie vie
tu es complètement du jeu est fini quand
ça sera le même dû selon vous est le
même dans la vie annonce alors je ne
crois pas l'interrompre s'énerve tout le
temps d'un après c'est vrai qu'il peut
faire le show et tous ces traders ont
encore une fois été très drôle
et pour ça le chaud parfois trop noir et
tu peut blesser des gens tu vas dire que
par des mots très beau grand il est nul
machin est à chier a raconté la télé ça
blesse et pour leur vécu compter l'autre
côté la télévision ça blesse c'est très
drôle mais ça blesse ou le dire il sait
pas lire
et dernier point alors oui alors d'aller
points ce qui me dérange le plus c'est
que tu es toujours toujours toujours du
côté de cyril tu allais du paped a pas
beaucoup de corps l'industrie des tests
arthur tu détestes arthur du tout qu'il
aime pas beaucoup guillon tu détestes
guillon maintenant ils adorent reichmann
t'adore à cheval tu es toujours tulle et
même détestation les mêmes à meetic
cyril pour ne jamais te poser mais je
termine la visite m'importe maintenant
c'est vrai mais c'est pas vrai valérie
mon vrai nom c'est pas vrai mais nous
disons merci de me serrer pas vrai non
porteuse non les bosseurs ça c'est vrai
toutes les émissions tu parles tout les
a regardés tu prépares bien les
émissions et dans la vraie vie tu as un
bon camarade c'est tout à l'antenne que
j'ai un petit soucis donc je note
l'antenne alors tu mets miens l'année
dernière je te mets 08 super days après
je vous dirais exactement la vérité
magali alors ils vont de temps vous fait
un peu mal aux oreilles mais ce qui est
bien avec vous c'est qu'on ne s'ennuie
jamais en plus vous êtes naturel vous
attendiez vous défendez toujours la
cause des femmes et sagem je regarde moi
je me dire ce que je pense de gilles
verdez je vous dis je vous dire la
vérité
gilles verdez est pour moi le meilleur
chroniqueur de touche pas d'accent bon
je vous le dis pour moi je niveau de
faire tous bien entendu mais c'est celui
qui a fait la plus belle rentrée se dit
la vérité une émission sur gilles verdez
je sais que c'est celui qui me manque le
plus quand il n'est pas là nous lie
parce que il a toujours un avis sur tout
ces avis sont tranchés
c'est c'est un garçon voilà sur guy
vraiment on peut compter et vraiment joe
lo dit gilles verdez c'est mon ami voilà
je le dis et c'est aussi voilà celui que
celui à qui je mettrai la meilleure note
pour moi il a joliment 9 912 pas selon
le guardian
pour moi de tes peines vraiment le fait
c'est sa vie c'est toujours tranché
qu'il est excellent et je rejoins
vraiment une aura sur la vie sur gilles
sur et valérie c'est aussi voilà voilà
donc valérie je te met huit et demi je
te veux juste j'ai juste un petit truc
voilà avec toi c'est parfois et c'est
normal ce que c'est c'est tuer comme ça
dans la terre c'était un peu trop gentil
et c'est vrai que c'est très bien mais
tu es en plus c'est moi je préfère qu'il
reste comme ça ma chérie mais c'est vrai
que parfois tu dis des choses en loge
que voilà tu arrives pas dire plus de
rondeur non mais tu m as tu n'avais plus
de rondeurs mais c'est ce qu'on aime
aussi chez toi ma chère et capucine adam
et bien elle a fait de très très gros
clairay et kanak chinois jours et me
voilà j'aurai 1007 parce que je trouve
qu'elle a elle a fait vraiment de très
très gros progrès depuis le début de
l'année et elles mêmes pourraient
progressant de non plus alors on va voir
la note d interpol allez plutôt ce pour
gilles 4,3 sur 10 arrêts donc voila tu
ne fait pas l'unanimité gilles mais
c'est normal parce que tu es très
tranchées et moyenne générale 4,4 sur
dix est ce que vous avez une réponse à
donner à tout ce qui s'est dit a déjà
cédé notre magnifique un vrai 4 en
général je croyais que je suis
enregistré un règlement de compte c'est
quasiment un plébiscite à zut je suis
très touché globalement c'est très
structuré vous avez beaucoup bossé
contrairement à d'habitude je propose
c'est que mathieu a dit totalement
n'importe quoi il a rien compris je lui
répondrais personnellement pour son
conseil de classe
le conseil d'état sera de mathieu ce
sera joli nom municipal a mouché annoncé
mercredi à merci et mercredi le conseil
de classe de mathieu mercredi ou
vendredi on va voir on va voir avec les
équipes de production mais ce sera
mercredi ou vendredi et jill vous êtes
quand même dernier mais vous êtes
content